the the problem is there a real problem
when it comes to masculinity assault on
masculinity war on men what do you think
I absolutely think there's a real
problem and uh it's not getting any
better it appears to be getting worse
it's it's uh something that a lot of
guys struggle with today um there's a
lot of weak soft docile uh men that
could be better versions of themselves
uh but they aren't uh and there's attack
on those guys too right I mean like
you've seen um you know attacks
yourselves in the media against a lot of
these men sometimes they're unfounded
sometimes they're founded but the the
it's difficult to distinguish you know
between the two because we live in a
world where it's believe all women now
today or believe anybody that accuses a
man of being toxic or anything that they
might do that's wrong until proven
otherwise and even if you do prove it
otherwise his name can be tarnished into
perpetuity for the women watching uh for
the empathetic males to the uh m
mainstream position I I think mainstream
is a fair fair qualification that um no
we have it backwards in this
conversation that uh there aspects of
masculinity that we have been allowed to
dominate in society to the disadvantage
of the overall and this is a necessary
correction and uh that it's about
creating more equity and fairness and
less toxicity in terms of how we
interact with each other and that's what
it is and if we don't like it that's
because we need to change I'm still
waiting for an example of that from from
that narrative from that side of the
story I haven't I haven't seen a example
where or a pile up of examples where men
are um as as described in that narrative
in that sound bite and I don't see any
situations where women can't do anything
that men can do in fact it's kind of
interesting because we live in a day and
age today where men who are abysmal I
can competing in their sport like
swimming you know for example uh ranked
400 or so will compete in a woman's
sport identify as a female and clean up
and be number one um so it's interesting
that that's overlooked or not pushed
back as uh as much as you know the
common average heterosexual male yeah I
mean look the without going down the
road of identity per say
um that example is an aberration I it
certainly gets trafficked in a lot to
make a point about um The Unfinished
Business of understanding identity and
and how we create equity in society uh
my big fear when it comes
to what is happening with my kids or any
of that stuff is not that my daughters
won't be able to compete in sports
anymore because the fields of play are
going to be filled with male males
posing as female but that is certainly
trafficked in a lot the big examp
example of uh the contrary position for
guys like the conversation that we're
having Richard is me too uh the toxic
workplace that men uh for Generations
were able to say and do whatever they
wanted to women and the women had to
comply uh or they would lose their jobs
or any sense of advantage that that is
what set all this off of rebalancing
patriarchy and matriarchy do we have
examples of that of of toxic workplaces
and men who've been able to get away
with things yeah I think I could make a
fairly compelling case that uh
workplaces I have worked in even in the
media up until recently and I would
actually argue until now because I think
a lot of me too has been underserved
with window dressing and just chasing
after media and bold-faced names
obviously I'm one of them um but did
they create real systemic change real
Equity Real Avenues of people to ask for
accountability that I don't know and
nobody follows up on that c coverage cuz
the boldface names are enough um but
again the proof of it would be that the
culture was that um men were in power
and could set the tone in the workplace
you disagree with that premise yeah I
disagree with that I mean I've I mean
I've worked in a number of workplaces
and I've been self-employed for I don't
know 20 25 years now but um even even
back when I was involved in the
corporate world and I work for some
large corporations you know I was
telling you before we went on the air
that I was involved in the credit and
collection industry and uh dealing with
that sort of work and there's some very
large institutions here um and I never
saw you know women treated any
differently than men um you get things
in uh passing you know there's comments
made in passing from the time to time
often in in uh in Jess sometimes not in
just but you know it's part of human
nature um I don't think that it's it's a
big issue and I don't think that it
should be tabled as a big issue in
today's world there's a lot bigger
problems that we have out there than he
was mean to me or he looked at me the
wrong way I really hope you guys enjoyed
that clip if you want to watch the full
length podcast you can find that over
here that clip's from if you're newer to
the channel make sure you hit subscribe
over here and pin down below in the top
comment you'll find a bunch of useful
links to my website my supplement line
books and a bunch of other stuff have an
amazing day peace out